moi je fais ce qu'il faut qu'ils aient
un des deux qui travaille à mi temps
mais c'est pas obligatoirement moi ça
peut être lui s'il a envie de s'occuper
des enfants
j'ai des exemples autour de moi qui
prouve que les filles qui arrivent à
avoir une certaine responsabilité sont
très rares une fille peut être pas avoir
autant de responsabilités qu'un garçon
et je vois pas pourquoi il ne
s'occuperait pas autant d de ses enfants
que que sa femme c'est lui qui les a
désiré autant qu'elle je vois pas
pourquoi ils prendraient pas autant de
responsabilités qu'elle
il suffit que les femmes elles ont
exactement les mêmes qualités que les
hommes donc elle doit avoir les mêmes
chances mais seulement via l'apa malkin
dit qu'ils ne le pensent pas et donc
pas mal c'est qui c'est les gens qui
portent comme toi c'est méchant j'ai le
bébé c'est une chose que j'aimerais pas
faire faire le ménage
pourquoi je sais pas ça me dégoûte ray j
ai alors dit ne sais pas je vais jouer
aussi mon rôle de père et des d'accord
ma femme mes subvenir aux besoins
financiers grecs à moi et pourquoi ça
parce que je suis né dans ça j'ai pris
le parti de mon père
toi tu as envie de travailler va imagine
qu'elle est raillée par nécessité voilà
l'idée façon qui est passé de leurs
salaires ne suffisent pas est ce que tu
peux ne suffit pas et imagine que selon
la situation avec ta femme veut
travailler et toi parce qu'il ya des
enfants le décide que tu restes à la
maison
vas-y 1 10 mois et ben pourquoi tu dis
ça pour moi l'homme est est toujours le
chef de famille lui il est encore dans
les temps anciens mais mauvais faut être
réaliste à se désoler chef de famille
aussi bien moi un chef de famille que
lui en toi si tu tombes sur quelqu'un
qui veut travailler qui veut avoir une
carrière ça va poser des problèmes jeu